[Music]
following the end of the great war
it was decided that a memorial should be
constructed that would encompass
all of those that fought and died
overseas and what was the great war
after much discussion on its shape and
where it was to be built it was decided
to create the cenotaph on its location
at gala street
this was based on a successful entry of
the submission by dunedin architects
combs and white
fitting the design parameters that the
memorial must be large
massive and strong big and feeling like
the men who nobody gave their lives for
us
secondly it should tower to a commanding
height to carry its meaning far and wide
forming a landmark for miles around the
memorial took the form of a cenotaph
similar to the one constructed in london
this design takes its name from the
greek words cenos md
and tafos tomb with so many bodies
buried in other countries it provided a
place for families and loved ones
to grieve and pay their respects the
structure was built from bluff granite
with the statue
of the tenderfoot soldier cut and
sculpted by g cancer the memorial was
unveiled in 1925.
the south and cenotaph holds the names
of over 2 000 men that have fought for
new zealand since the first world war